[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir reza
jafari président de l'association
enfants d'afghanistan bonsoir eisa
jafari merci d'être avec nous régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france merci
régis d'être là donc à moi un jour pour
jour après la prise de kaboul reza
jafari quelle est la situation sur place
ce que vous avez des remontées
d'afghanistan
oui bien sûr à kaboul comme on sait
qu'il ya encore la présence de
quelques journalistes on a des images
les talibans sans ont sorti les fous et
on est retourné dans les années
quatre-vingt seize mais par contre dans
les zones reculées et dans les autres
provinces comme dans le vallée du
panjshir dans la province du panchir où
il y à une guerre les talibans les
tribunaux talibans ont commencé à donner
les ordres d'exécution mais aussi dans
les autres provinces comme le province
de daykundi qui est majoritairement
habité par les hasards a qui sont
minoritaires en afghanistan et
ce matin plusieurs centaines d des
habitants de province de kandahar ont
manifesté parce que les talibans les
oblige à se déplacer et à partir dans
les autres provinces parce que
apparemment ils ont un projet de faire
venir d'autres mondes d'ailleurs et les
installer à kandahar mais ce monde et
vient d'où pour l'instant c'est on pense
qu' il veut faire venir aider des
pachtouns qui sont de l'autre côté de d1
tribales
c'est à dire le pakistan et les faire
revenir à kandahar non c'est pas très
optimiste le saunier ce que nous dit
reza jafarzadeh ont s'en voit une
volonté de reprise à la vie normale par
les talibans évidemment qu'ils veulent
être on l'a dit souvent un interlocuteur
pour notamment les occidentaux bah ils
ont fait une opération clairement de
séduction de l'occident en même temps il
ya deux messages chez les talibans
clairement la composition du
gouvernement qu'ils ont donnée est à une
opposition qui est à destination de
leurs troupes qui rassemble d'ailleurs
les différentes tendances en entendu le
ou le secrétaire de l'union européenne
déclaré qu'ils avaient des tensions au
sein des talibans et que la situation
n'était pas stable au niveau
gouvernemental elle ne l'est pas en
effet on sait qu'il ya une opposition
depuis longtemps entre le réseau haqqani
enfin la famille le clan haqqani qui
tient une partie de l'appareil militaire
taliban et le mollah baradar qui le
négociateur qui était le négociateur en
chef à doha et que l'un et l'autre d'une
représentation dans le gouvernement donc
en fait le gouvernement a été un message
à destination des troupes dalida à
destination de ceux qui avaient gagné
des vainqueurs et pas tellement à
destination de l'international où les
américains et la communauté avait pressé
pour qu'il y ait là l'inclusion d'un
certain nombre de personnes de la
société civile et éventuellement de
l'opposition il n'y a rien du tout ça
jusqu'à présent et en même temps on a vu
les taliban continuer à tolérer
effectivement que les journalistes
fassent leur métier même s'il est
encadrée même s'il ya des contraintes
continue à documenter ce qui se passe et
notamment à kaboul et en août on les a
vus aussi on a vu les déclarations
remerciant la communauté internationale
appelant aussi on l'a vu aussi à des
nouvelles relations avec les états unis
a souhaité ce qui est des bonnes
relations qui se tissent sous les
talibans sont pas naïfs ils savent que
aujourd'hui une crise humanitaire une
crise alimentaire en afghanistan qui va
petit touche à peu près un tiers de la
population afghane c'est énorme et qu'
ils ne pourront pas continuer à se
maintenir au pouvoir s'il ya une énorme
famille en afghanistan parce que les
afghans d'une certaine façon une partie
de la population fait confiance aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre 40 20
ans d'occupation américaines 40 ans de
guerre beaucoup d'afghans sont
complètement là c est se disent
finalement si les talibans arrivent à
apporter la paix ben pourquoi pas les
mais voilà et la télévision
sélectivement les finances est un
minimum pour survivre mais c'est en cela
que la population les a à l'oeil d'une
certaine façon l'afghanistan est un pays
ingouvernable
c'est un pays qui a toujours été
traversé par des envahisseurs qui n'ont
jamais pu s'y maintenir et les taliban
compris donc ils savent très bien qu'il
peut y avoir aussi des révoltes qui peut
y avoir des zones qui leur échappe et
asseoir leur pouvoir sur l'ensemble du
pays est une condition et cette
condition passe par le maintien d'une
activité économique de flux financiers
et la gestion d'un pays ce qu'ils n'ont
pas fait depuis entendre puisqu'ils
n'ont pas été au pouvoir depuis un an
dans tout ce temps-là ravinement
justement les âges a failli rendre avant
de parler de la destination de ces aides
quelle est la situation en ce moment on
nous parlons parce qu'on sait que le
retrait américain a été l'occasion de
l'arrêt des aides de la communauté
internationale la situation est critique
notamment pour les plus faibles les
enfants par exemple
la plupart des gens sont en train de
vendre leurs affaires leurs biens même
leur maison il y en a beaucoup qui
essayent de partir et quitter le pays
parce qu'ils veulent pas vivre à
solrinnes des talibans il faut rappeler
que ça fait 20 ans la nouvelle
génération a connu que la république
vécu si j'aimerais public aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que la famine touche la
population afghane et que
sûrement il va il y a déjà des
oppositions des fronts de résistances
dans le pays et mais avec les dernières
nouvelles qu'on a partout en afghanistan
le peuple est en train de se lever
contre ce régime en tout cas l'union
européenne elle redoute vraiment une
crise humanitaire dans le pays elle
annonce vouloir renforcer son aide à
destination de l'afghanistan la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen s'exprimer sur ce
sujet
nous devons continuer à soutenir tous
les afghans dans le pays et dans les
pays voisins nous devons tout faire pour
éviter le risque réel d'une famille
majeure et d'une catastrophe humanitaire
et nous ferons notre part nous
augmenterons à nouveau l'aide
humanitaire à l'afghanistan de 100
millions d'euros cela fera partie d'un
nouveau paquet de soutien à gand plus
large que nous présenterons dans les
prochaines semaines pour unir tous nos
efforts
régis dont l'union européenne qui met la
main à la poche à nouveau l'onu 1 kg
s'est engagé à verser elle plus d'un
milliard d'euros dead
ondelettes sans contrepartie pour le
moment est ce que on est certains c'est
une bonne stratégie puisque on le donne
forcément au gouvernement taliban qui va
le gérer pour la population c'est
toujours le problème de des commandes d
aide humanitaire c'est à dire de savoir
qu'elle fait la réalité de la rom
entendu un des porte parole taliban a
assuré la communauté internationale que
cette aide serait bien acheminé
c'est très particulier bien sûr le
contexte est particulier et bien sûr
qu'on a aucune certitude que cette aide
va bien par exemple vous parlez des
hasards à tout à l'heure il ya un
certain nombre de populations comme ça
qui sont directement la cible des
talibans depuis très longtemps a même
sous l'occupation américaine il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui sont voilà
visé est ce que ces gens s'ils sont en
besoin avant de recevoir cette aide rien
n'est moins sûr est ce que les talibans
vont la partager déjà entre eux et parle
pour les populations qu'elles
n'entendent dont ils ont le support ça
pour moi elle fera sûrement pouvoir il
va falloir pour qui une réalité tangible
et puis surtout ce qu'ils aimeraient
faire la communauté internationale on le
sent bien mais il n'y a pas vraiment de
de menaces ni de des changes c'est
d'assurer par exemple que le droit des
femmes le vent des femmes un travail et
le droit des femmes à étudier soit
garantie par les taliban les talibans
ont assuré mais est ce que dans une
deuxième phase ils vont pas dire
finalement dans la charia la femme doit
être au foyer puisque c'est souvent sur
ces textes là en disant nous
appliquerons la charia qui peuvent se
permettre d'adopter un double discours
là pour le moment ils ont officiellement
autorisé les femmes à se rendre à
l'université on l'a vu avec des
contraintes particulières dont il
dévoile et puis surtout au sahel elles
sont autorisées à partir cinq minutes
avant les hommes pour passerelles angers
ça c'est une obsession des talibans
c'est que les hommes et les femmes ne se
croisent jamais ça fait partie de ce
qu'on remarque quand on va passer du
temps avec eux c'est qu'il ya une espèce
de volaille et une cloison en absolu
dans la société civile entre hommes et
femmes est une est donc l université ils
ont commencé à appliquer ça donc pas
interdit aux femmes de retourner à
l'université ce qui n'était pas le cas
dans la précédente administration
talibane là il n'y avait pas de besoin
de faire des appels du pied à la
communauté internationale d'aider facto
l'afghanistan était devenu internet à
part ya les talibans n'ont pas
réellement cherché à avoir de l'aide je
dirais comme comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui joue une
partition qui est leur survie ils savent
très bien qu'il ya des points de
fragilité on afghanistan comme je le
répète
c'est un pays extrêmement difficile à
contrôler toutes les zones de l'est sont
des zones qui est la plupart du temps et
échappé au pouvoir central comme par
hasard c'est que la dèche s'était
implanté je parle de l'est et du nord
les provinces de kunar de langage qui
sont extrêmement difficiles à contrôler
tout ce qui est autour de la frontière
et les talibans savent bien que pour
asseoir leur pouvoir il va leur falloir
des finances il va leur falloir une
économie va leur falloir une
administration et ils ont tout intérêt à
coopérer avec la communauté
internationale après à la communauté
internationale effectivement de données
en fonction peut-être de monnaie
d'échangé de poids faire pression sur ce
gouvernement taliban est justement le
secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio goûter res
exhorté les pays justement à mettre la
main à la poche écouter
le peuple afghan a besoin d'une bouée de
sauvetage après des décennies de guerres
de souffrance et d'insécurité il est
peut être confronté à son oeuvre la plus
périlleuse
un aïeul jeetoo se porte en flèche et
pire je vous demande instamment de
soutenir notre appel éclair de 606
millions de dollars afin d'apporter une
aide urgente à 11 millions de personnes
au cours des quatre prochains mois nous
annonçons aujourd'hui une allocation de
20 millions de dollars du fonds central
d'intervention d'urgence des nations
unies pour soutenir l'opération
humanitaire en afghanistan mais les
terrils operation in afghanistan
résa jafari et antonio guterres est un
qui veut se servir de cet argent il le
disait comme levier pour tous les autres
aspects qui préoccupent la communauté
internationale citant le terrorisme la
drogue les droits humains il ya une
forme de naïveté pour vous chez l'homme
le secrétaire
nationale de pardon le cinq national
secrétaire général je vais y arriver des
nations unies est-ce que vous en tant
qu'humanitaires vous êtes à peu près
confiant sur la destination de cet
argent non non pas du tout
beaucoup ont tiré de leçon à par les
occidentaux et
d'abord les américains qui font un
accord avec les talibans avec une bande
des terroristes qu'on les appelait
encore il y a quelques mois et
maintenant ça devient un gouvernement
légitime en négociant avec eux on leur
donne plus de légitimité et aujourd'hui
on parle d'un raz de créer un rapport de
force avec les talibans elle est un jour
le depuis le début et ce qu'ils ont tenu
un de leurs engagements mais jamais ils
parlaient d'un gouvernement inclusif
aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement d qui
est composé dé des
talibans des terroristes recherchés par
le monde entier pour vous il fallait
verser cette aide il faut verser cette
aide justement pour la population il n'y
a pas le choix ou au contraire ça peut
être un moyen de pression ça peut être
un moyen de négociation avec les
talibans surtout depuis les débuts où on
crie qu'il faut maintenant négocier avec
les talibans pour ouvrir les couloirs
humanitaires pour les gens qui veulent
sortir puisse le faire et en même temps
soutenir le zéro indjai et ne pas donner
tous aux talibans pour qu'ils soient un
petit peu dépendante des ong qui sont il
ya encore quelques ong courageuses qui
sont restés en afghanistan qu'ils sont
sur place dès qu'on les connaît ils font
un travail extraordinaire sur place mais
aujourd'hui travailler avec le
gouvernement taliban là
les américains je pense que c'est en
train de regretter déjà avec les accords
de doha et que la communauté
internationale va être de toute façon
obligé à coopérer à travailler avec les
talibans mais ce travail va être de plus
en plus c'est difficile et compliqué
puisqu'il il n'y a pas de queue présence
de la communauté internationale en
afghanistan ne peut pas surveiller et
que les talibans à aucun moment on peut
faire confiance à une bande je rappelle
encore une fois une bande de terroristes
et justement propos des américains
dernière question un peu plus politique
régissant selon les journées du
washington post en plusieurs ministres
américain et membres de l'otan ont tenté
de convaincre jo maiden de pousser le
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan de repousser et évidemment
ça fait polémique jova et donne aurait
refusé par crainte d'être embourbé dans
le pays ça vous semble crédible cette
information était possible en tout cas
ce qu'on sait c'est que quand anthony
blinken jeux d'antan dès hier soir
déclaré devant le congrès que le
renseignement américains n'avaient pas
prévu un écroulement aussi rapides de
direction
moi j'étais en afghanistan juillet et je
peux vous dire que deux choses d'abord à
l'époque des embuscades y en avait à 10
km de kaboul les talibans étaient
vraiment à l'extérieur ce que ton est
allé rencontrer à l'époque pour faire un
documentaire dans leur zone contrôlé la
plupart des provinces à quelques
kilomètres du centre ville et étaient
capables d'ailleurs de tendre des
embuscades jusque dans les zones
gouvernementales donc on sentait
vraiment cette fragilité on sentait
aussi que kaboul à l'est et à l'ouest en
tout cas moi j'ai pu le conteste le
constater n'était pas défendu il y avait
une médaille sharks était une ville
charnière où là il y avait un peu de
présence de l'armée la green zone là où
étaient les américains ou et toutes les
ambassades et toutes les administrations
elles étaient défendues si vous voulez
mais la ville en tant que telle n'était
pas défendu que jalalabad idem on a su
après que jalal abad pendant deux mois
avait été l'objet de négociations entre
les talibans et qu'il n'y a pas eu un
coup de feu lors de la reddition de la
ville ça c'est le premier aspect
deuxième aspect si moi je me souviens
des discussions que j'ai eues avec david
david martinon l'ambassade offre de
france c'était au début juillet qui me
disait que le 17 juillet la france a
comment apprêter un vol pour rapatrier
c'est que ses ressortissants quatre vols
avaient déjà eu lieu depuis mai pour
rapatrier aussi les traducteurs et un
certain nombre d'interprètes et des gens
qui souhaitaient quitter l'afghanistan
sur le le constat que y allait avoir un
écroulement rapide donc la question que
je me pose c'est quel est ce que les
français avaient des informations que
les américains n'avaient pas parce que
les français ont ont replié en bon ordre
et ont affrété je vous dis dès juillet
donc c'est on est un mois avant la chute
de kaboul un avion pour dire à ceux qui
sont dans le pays c'est votre dernière
chance partait donc là la question c'est
quand blinken nous dit nous nous
n'avions pas d'informations
le renseignement américain ont donné ses
propres doutes tout simplement faux et
je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
américains n'ont pas anticipé et ça
c'est vraiment de la faute de joe biden
on peut pas accuser l'administration
précédente donald trump ou jones et y
d'avoir provoqué ce qu'est cette
catastrophe rezaï a fait il le mot de la
fin les avirons que vous avez j'imagine
sur place peut être parfois par vous
échangez peut-être avec eux il y un
sentiment de trahison justement quand on
voit ce retrait américain un peu
catastrophique
quel est le sentiment de la population
sur place depuis vingt ans des promesses
déprendre de promesses en l'air des
promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues et
qu'au final l'afghanistan étaient vendus
par keynes a été rendu
talibans et comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure c'était un accord avec les
allées les talibans s'étaient les
accords de doha est aujourd'hui les
afghans surtout la nouvelle génération
se sont vraiment trahi non seulement par
les américains mais aussi par son propre
gouvernement par la communauté
internationale aujourd'hui tout le monde
abandonne l'afghanistan et la génération
est ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui
c'est de ne pas abandonner son peuple et
soutenir surtout cette nouvelle
génération qui est attachée aux valeurs
qu'on partage
tous ici parce que la nouvelle
génération comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est une génération qui a grandi sous
une république c'est une démocratie s'il
y avait une certaine liberté
d'expression on perd tout ça et surtout
les femmes ceux qui ont bâti pendant
toute ces dernières années elles perdent
tout du jour au lendemain ils vont
résister malgré le danger de mort et je
suis sûr que l on réussira pas seulement
aujourd'hui presque il y à 37 millions
afghans en afghanistan les talibans
quand ils sont arrivés c'était vers 60
mille aujourd'hui si le l'afghanistan
est tombé assez rapidement parce qu'il y
avait des dirigeants corrompus on n'a
fait que trop confiance aux chefs de
guerre déjà en 96 si les talibans ont
réussi à prendre le l'organiste ans
c'était parce que il en avait marre des
moudjahidine et des chefs de guerre
aujourd'hui on a fait la même erreur de
faire confiance au chef de guerre qui
ont dès que les talibans sont arrivés
ont quitté l'afghanistan merci